[Applaudissements]
deux ans qu'ils attendaient les joies
d'une victoire après deux saisons
blanches suite à la crise sanitaire les
templiers d'elancourt ont réussi leur
grand retour sur les terrains de
deuxième division avec une victoire face
aux dragons de paris ce samedi 15
janvier un match remporté avec la
manière score final 18 à 0 en vrai il
n'y a pas de match facile il ya des
matchs maîtriser c'est tout est là on a
su maîtriser avec un bon coaching staff
des bois no comment dire des bonnes
consignes et après derrière il ya une
bonne exécution a que comme ça qu'on
peut réussir de toute façon mais a que
comme ça qu'on peut faire des clean
sheets donc on en a fait un ce soir et
on compte en faire d'autres je suis pas
surpris ça fait déjà un an et demi qu'on
s'entraîne ça fait un an et demi comme
ça sont hyper remontée et franchement ça
soit sur tout le match l'équipe en face
n'a pas réussi à avancer c'est ce qu'on
voulait si le match s'est déroulé dans
la brume les objectifs du club sont
claires cette saison la montée pour
retrouver la première division
l'esprit coubertin on l'a on sait que
l'important c'est de participer mais on
veut aussi gagner en fait on fait ce
sport ça sport de compétition notre but
c'est d'aller en finale de passer ces
play-offs d'aller en finale l'objectif
c'est d'être invaincus l'objectif c'est
d'aller en finale l'objectif c'est de
gagner la finale et l'objectif forcément
ces montants nietzsche est temps qu'on
perd pas et c'est ce qu'on va faire et
maintenant qu'on perd pas assez on va
aller en élite on va aller encore plus
loin le but c'est d'aller en élite c'est
de gagner l'élite c'est d'aller en
europe puisse gagner l'europe aussi s'en
remettra deux en un an deux ans trois
ans qu'on le fera pour confirmer leur
bon début de saison et continuer à rêver
d'une montée en fin d'année les
templiers d'elancourt se déplaceront ce
29 janvier sur le terrain des docks
earth de lente
[Applaudissements]
puisque